[Music]
welcome you all to the seventh annual
Henry Kendall lecture before we begin
the main lecture itself it's become a
tradition to give out an award that is
given out annually called the global
habitat longevity award it was donated
or available through a kind donation of
Frederick Middleton who unfortunately
can't be here today and it is given in
the general area of global change but
particularly looking at the evolutionary
processes that have occurred on our
planet over geologic time and the winner
this year is Dan Rothman from each
department and his he is being
recognized for his work on the
Proterozoic er a carbon cycle through to
the younger times the Proterozoic goes
back to a billion years ago so this is
quite different than what Steve
Schneider will tell us about for the
next hundred or two years this is going
back to a billion years but Dan has
brought some novel statistical
approaches to the study of time series
of various proxies of the carbon cycle
going back in time and has mightily
pleased the geologists who are quite
impressed with you Dan so you've
obviously made a significant
contribution so it's my pleasure to ask
you to just come forward and accept a
little certificate and there's a little
letter here from a couple of higher-ups
but the cheque there's no cheque in here
yet you'll apparently get an account it
does come with an award of $25,000 for
research and I'm sure that Dan will make
very good use of it
so as I mentioned this is the seventh
annual Henry Kendall lecture and just
let me introduce myself I'm Ron Prinn I
direct MIT Center for global change
science and usually end up introducing
this this lecture because in fact it was
a conversation with me and the donor
who's Kurt Gottfried at Cornell
University that set up this this lecture
in honor of Henry
as most of you of course know Henry won
a Nobel Prize in Physics but he also had
a deep and abiding interest in the
environment and many environmental
issues and in fact when the center for
global change science was set up in 1990
he came up as he always looks a little
disabled roughed up and said this is a
great event because finally people were
getting together who should in order to
think about how the climate system works
and not just how the atmosphere by
itself or the ocean by itself and so on
and of course as you know as most of you
know Henry died rather tragically in an
accident but he is certainly remembered
for his contributions to physics but
also well remembered for his
contributions to environmental issues he
set up this declaration that I think
you've all picked up a copy of a rather
famous declaration and I think it sort
of tells you his vision it was signed by
a very large number of people including
a large number of other nobel laureates
and it's basically a philosophy and
States's philosophy with it certainly I
share of a need to be a steward to the
planet we're on and not just gather all
of the things from it without thinking
about it's its sustenance going into the
future
I would normally say more about Henry
about how this year's lecture and knows
knew Henry well and I think in his talk
will fold in some memories of
interactions with Henry Kendall in his
lecture so the seventh lecture of this
year it's my considerable pleasure to
introduce Professor Steve Snyder from
Stanford University
Steve and I in fact go back a long time
I think we first met probably in about
1971 or 72 and had about the two where I
think we both got our degree in the same
year and we've known each other since
then and have had a lot of really
enjoyable interactions it is my job to
sort of read out a few formal things
about Steve's career and so let me do
that he's currently the Melvin and John
Wayne professor for interdisciplinary
environmental studies at Stanford he's
also a professor of biological sciences
and a professor of civil environmental
engineering
he co-directed the center for
environmental science and policy at
Stanford and he's a senior fellow in the
woods Institute at that University he
received his PhD in mechanical
engineering and plasma physics from
Columbia University and I was right in
1971 his early work was studying the
role of greenhouse gases and aerosols at
NASA's Goddard Institute for Space
Studies and that's when I first met him
and he was working with a wonderful
character named misty aqua azul some of
you may remember him he was a member of
the scientific staff of ncar that's
where he moved from from gifts to in car
in 1973 was there through 1996 where he
co-founded the climate project at NCAR
no surprise given the topic of his
lecture his research focuses on climate
change science but also under an
integrated assessment of ecological and
economic impacts of climate change he
while he's worked a lot on identifying
viable climate policies in recent years
and technological solutions consulted
with federal agencies and the how and
the hill the agents and the the house
and the Senate through many many
administrations beginning the Nixon and
going through the Carter and Reagan and
Clinton and Bush administration's I
won't tell you which ones he enjoyed
most but he's actively involved in the
IPCC and he's currently a coordinating
lead author of one of the main chapters
in working group two there
titled assessing key vulnerabilities and
the risk from climate change as many of
you know the IPCC summaries from the
Working Group 1 and working group 2
who've just come out one of them on
February 2 and the other one about two
weeks ago and are available on the IPCC
web if you wish to consult them Steve
has won many awards the American the
American Association for the Advancement
of science Westinghouse award he's won a
MacArthur Fellowship in 1992 he's
elected to membership in the National
Academy of Sciences in 2002 many other
honors I won't and some of them are
written down and the invitation you
would have received he's the founder and
still the editor of the
interdisciplinary journal climatic
change that I can vouch as a excellent
journal having published a lot of stuff
in it myself but it's a tough it's a
tough referees system that they have it
took a year to get through it was a mega
paper but it did take again a year to
get through the system he's authored and
co-authored you know hundreds of papers
and so on and is very well-known as I
say not just in the science but
particularly in recent years in in
trying to bridge over into the economics
and policy areas so with that as a
preamble Steve welcome to MIT and we're
all looking forward to your lecture
thanks very much for that Ron oh it is
on okay
and it's just a pleasure to be back and
to see old friends and old mentors and
in fact sitting and talking with Ed
Lorenz just today your name came up he I
didn't tell you this yet when I was
meeting with about 20 graduate students
and and we were talking about everything
from climate science and and some
impacts but a lot of people were asking
policy-driven questions and coupling of
economics and technology and so forth
and I just dawned on me while I was
sitting in the very building that I
first came to in probably 1974 when you
had two students Alan robock and another
one that you asked me to help you to
work with that the conversation that we
had crossing so many disciplines with
competence in the multiple disciplines
would have been virtually inconceivable
in 1974 although those two students
actually were thinking about it but
didn't think about it out loud I had
always had academic freedom as a driving
force and then I thought that when I was
back again maybe in the late 80s we did
have conversations like that but
probably to students now there are 20 so
I think it's a compliment to you that
you've taken not just the good basic
science but that the integration of that
into either looking for emergent
properties of coupled systems the
intellectual side or looking to try to
deal with problems you know where they
are across multiple disciplines is great
so it was really terrific fun for me
because it's that next generation of
students of which I see many will have
to figure out how to fix the problem
that my generation is leaving you okay
in that sense
let me talk a bit first about Henry
Kendall and it's probably in there so I
can read it quickly but just a few
descriptions for those who may not know
I had the pleasure and the privilege of
working with him on a number of
occasions I'll talk about one in a
minute so he was the recipient of the
Nobel Prize as we heard and the citation
was for pioneering investigations
concerning
deep inelastic scattering of electrons
and on protons and bound neutrons which
have been of essential importance to the
development of the quark model and
particle physics I'm going to show you
later a quote from a White House
Conference that has absolutely nothing
to do with any of this which has to do
with the the breadth of his capacity not
only accomplished as a physicist and a
skilled Mountaineer and photographer but
one of the founding members of the Union
of Concerned Scientists and active
throughout his life to advance the
causes of ucs particularly interested in
energy and nuclear proliferation in 97
kendall and this lecturer Co appeared
before an East Room White House
Conference kicked off the clinton-gore
administration's public campaign for
u.s. participation in the Kyoto Protocol
so there's the photo-op
you might even recognize a few
colleagues and others it had a heavy
dependence on Nobel laureates I never
quite understood that but then a few
other people and then it had one really
good movie star and with what
Al Gore I forgot the name of the doctor
lest something there's why who was this
Henry Jane Lubchenco sherry Rowland john
holdren the guy in the suit me the guy
in the light suit we were dressed down
for this up for this round dress
behavior Mario Molina and then there's
this guy who also is well known for some
things okay now he was terrific
so now let's get to Henry I'd know these
quotes because I happen to have had the
transcript so I can give them to you
since I was there so here we were in the
East Room and this was the first public
event in which the president
vice-president wanted to introduce the
public to the debate about the Kyoto
Protocol just to tell you how successful
it was that day the US Senate passed
sense of the Senate resolution called
buried Hegel 95 to nothing saying that
they wouldn't sign on any protocol that
didn't include a meaningful
participation of developed country
developing countries China India and so
forth while forgetting to mention that
we were a factor of 10 per capita energy
more using that they were they left that
little detail out and so there was no
there was no naivete in the part of the
President the Vice President about what
the task was going to be like and I
remember thinking it's great there in it
but why is this July of 97 with the
protocol to be negotiated in December it
should have been July of 94 because it
takes a long time to get people used to
a problem but they did it anyhow so this
was from Henry it's the bottom tier the
developing nations that will get hit
directly by shortages helping to
generate increasing numbers of hungry
migrants environmental refugees
streaming across national borders the
result is that no nation will be
sheltered from dislocation of food
supplies altered trade balances fresh
water difficulties and even by the way
that's very similar to what you just
heard two weeks ago from the release of
the IPCC working group to report except
this happened to have been ten years
earlier and even though the wealthy
nations will remain able to feed
themselves no nation will escape the
troubles from pressures on the food
supply
and then he had a line I just loved and
so did Clinton he repeated it mr.
president it's not the case that one end
of a boat can sink as in we're okay and
they're not living in the same world
with dependence on and your systems and
vulnerability to all kinds of chicanery
and he framed it just to give you the
rest of the sentence then we'll move on
he framed it so there it is so let me
say this is a developing problem in
national security which now again I just
heard six retired military brass frame
it as it took a long time but he was ten
years ahead again and we have to deal
with it the best way to deal with it and
I'm gonna come back to this philosophy
in a minute at the end of the I guess
near the middle of talk the best way to
deal with with problems of this sort is
to stop them at the outset and not wait
until the results are presented to us
and great troubles have developed in
other words a statement of the
precautionary principle rather than a
principle of let's get high confidence
degrees of certainty that I will argue
which this this precautionary principle
is at variance with the views of a lot
of other people and I'll contrast that
later in the current IPCC okay so again
it's a thrill for me and thank you very
much Ron for the invitation to remember
Henry who's a one-of-a-kind and the mold
broke when he died okay time to talk
about my chapter and other things the
chapter has a direct remit from the
government's their hundred and hundred
and twenty governments give us what we
call the PIO the hallowed pio as
somebody calls it which is our plenary
agreed outline it's the bullet points
upon which you must put in your chapter
discussions of all those issues and the
discussions have to be based upon
references in the literature and our job
is not just simply to be librarians and
cite what's out there they don't need us
for that it's to make judgments about
the relative quality of the literature
and then to assign confidence to various
conclusions because that's what's
difficult to do in the political media
debate
with 20 seconds sound bites of
end-of-the-world and good for you
advocates when I will tell you my own
prejudice is at end of the world and
good for you the two lowest probability
outcomes in the debate and therefore
that's recognized and governments do
actually want to have a more credible
set of assessments in the US it's a
National Research Council Australia
CSIRO does it the UK has other things
but those aren't credible outside of
those countries or other countries like
them so the IPCC was created for the
purpose of engaging the literally the
whole international community
so the chapter includes in its plenary
agreed outline in the science of article
to article 2 is UN Framework Convention
about what is dangerous so I thought I'd
start with a very large trillion dollar
scale industry Munich Rea the
reinsurance company the ones who have to
pay the families of the 40,000 people
who died in the Euro heatwave in 2003
and companies lost in floods and and the
Katrina victims so they obviously not
surprisingly think that the climate
change experiment does Roger Revelle
called it once the Roger Revelle and
haunt Seuss the great geophysical
experiment we were performing they think
it's dangerous and to their financial
interests they're probably right but
what does it mean well here's the UN
Framework Convention language don't
worry we won't read it all just a couple
of key points stabilization of
greenhouse gas concentrations in the
atmosphere at a level would prevent and
here's the famous phrase dangerous
anthropogenic interference with the
climate system did it define that not
quite a level should be achieved within
a time frame so they recognize a
transients matter and I would when
somebody says well how much climate
change you worried about I said well I
would rather have three degrees in two
hundred years and two degrees and 50
because the adaptive capacity of social
systems and natural systems depends on
rates so it's not a simple answer you
have to look at the system the
thresholds that matter the rates at
which they are in your capacity so they
got that right which was pretty good for
189 countries signed this second-most
signed and ratified treaty and by the
way President Bush once signed it in the
US Senate ratified it this is the law of
the land something I wish another Bush
might remember what else to allow
ecosystems to adapt naturally to ensure
food production is not threatened and
enable economic development to proceed
in a sustainable manner the last one is
very interesting because you can
interpret it two ways it's very hard to
sustain your economic development if
you're in a coastal a small island state
and you're underwater or you're about to
be so you could talk about damages to
the system and say that that wouldn't be
sustainable on the other hand if you're
a state entirely dependent on coal
burning and you haven't figured out how
to sequester the co2 underground or
switch cost-effectively to other systems
then your sustainable development can be
hurt by the action so therefore the
balance and this is why it's such an
interesting politically difficult issue
at an international scale is balancing
damages against costs of fixing them and
not necessarily John in a cost-benefit
framework but certainly intellectually
you have to look at the wide ranges but
the other thing that matters is that the
damages that will occur are highly
differential for example melting Arctic
sea ice will cause the damage to the
shipping industry of probably saving
them 50 million dollars a year in having
shorter routes but it will wreck the
culture of the inner wits which has
established over 5,000 years how do you
weigh that or destroy the polar bear
ecosystem how do you weigh those
incomparable monetary metrics well you
don't you have a political argument
about the relative importance of those
things so therefore what we have to do
when we discuss this issue is to frame
it in the multiple metrics that people
care about and later on to be make a
political decision at an international
level about the relative importance of
those so analysis is essential but at
the same time the analysis can't
aggregate everything all at once first
without controversies that was all
that's basically I've given you what our
chapter has to point out and how we do
it will come out okay so first of all
who decides what is dangerous when we
were first asked by
to do this we said the obvious we can't
tell you what's dangerous dangerous is a
value judgment about the acceptability
of risks and they said well you're the
experts who said well we're the experts
and what can happen and what are the
odds risks we're not the experts in what
to do but we can do is we can survey the
literature see what different
stakeholders different nations different
sectors different groups are worried
about in terms of thresholds that if
exceeded would be in their opinion
dangerous we can give you criteria for
what vulnerabilities are key but then
it's your job to pick them so so far
we've had a reasonably occasionally
uneasy balance with governments and they
did just to prove it
so I guess that metric worked but the
key is it's not a scientific judgment to
decide dangerous but it's not a lay
judgment to decide risk so we're all
needed in this equation ok so there's
many ways to define it and it's
ultimately as I just said not a
scientific choice and now we have
another problem we have the problem that
everything has uncertainty is
uncertainty and how many people in the
world standards of living they'll demand
technologies we'll use how policies will
form just from the perception that there
is a dangerous outcome which leads to a
different policy that then messes up
your original calculation all of that is
part of the story and there's
uncertainty and all the bio geophysical
stuff as well so therefore you're not
going to do an optimization with with
about seven median values of important
parameters and get an answer that's
honest what you're gonna do is put in
bell curves on all of them and then you
end up the problem of well how do you do
that when you don't have enough data to
do it so that's where I'm gonna take us
so it started out with best guesses so
you had a best guess for climate for
people and for emissions and for climate
sensitivity right how much it warms up
if you're double co2 that's climate
sensitivity and then you have best
guesses for how what the damages are and
you can come up with a number in that
framework you can optimize how much does
it cost you know to fix the problem
versus how much it costs if you don't
but we know that's not right so we
started working on ranges and the famous
Charney reports long as we're at MIT how
could I
not mention that which first defined
climate sensitivity as a range 1.5 to
4.5 C and I don't remember what that was
supposed to include who I think it was a
1090 range but I can't recall and what
it was was a subjective assessment but
an expert assessment looking at what was
available and then guessing what was
missing in the models and trying to
account for it and what I like so much
about that report wasn't the number
which lived for 25 years by the way
until the current report but that they
explained the process and that's really
important that they were very open about
that but of course what we really need
is not just ranges if we're gonna do
risk management we need PDFs now you all
know how easy it is to talk about
something like a PDF on the evening news
or in front of Congress they all know
what a PDF is yeah of course we now oh
sorry guys that's not the PDF we're
talking about we're talking about this
one so here's a PDF so it's a
probability density function and I'm
glad in this group I don't have to
explain it because if I do public talks
and I show these pictures it's about 6
minutes to explain this and I have to
tell people well you know there's a 10%
chance if you look at the area under the
curve that's called the cdf don't worry
what that means so we have a 10% chance
of a 10% eye out 10 which means 90%
chance it's more than 110 percent it's
less you've here you are out here with
an unbounded tail that goes out for a
while without much probability but you
have a 10% chance it's more than four
iceage interglacials cycle differences
in much less time that's one that even
the outgoing former outgoing CEO of
Exxon wouldn't recommend so you end up
with these catastrophic outcomes and
these well we'd probably would rather
not have it but we could manage that you
know a lot better and they're all out
there now this particular one was for
one scenario for a for a probability
density function of climate sensitivity
which I think we stole from your paper
Chris and then your group's paper
and we have the standard mantra please
don't take numerical model dependent
results literally please take framework
seriously so this is a framework that
we're trying to talk about and I still
remember when I first showed this a
while back I don't know John you may
have even been in the room I may have
been at EMF and somebody started to
complain and we're having salmon for
dinner and started to clean come on
Steve you mean you only think there's a
10% chance of really catastrophic
outcomes you want to alter the basis of
industrial civilization denied the
Chinese and the Indians the chance to
catch up with a Victorian Industrial
Revolution and I remember saying well
you know we're eating salmon Joe
although I think it was Rob and I said
there's only a 10% chance of salmonella
in the salmon of course you're going to
eat it right and and it led to a little
thing that I a little decision analytic
elicitation I have now done with all
groups of reasonable size why not would
this one so 10% he thought was way to
lower probability for a significant
action that cost trillions of dollars
and of course these are not trivial
events either they're just not as bad as
those so I then said okay how many
people in the room let's do it with this
crowd - let's see what I see if how you
come out in this and in this little
informal survey how many people have had
a significant house fire couple well
that's around this is a good crowd
because normally it's a little higher
than that
in Berkeley it was a lot but that's a
special case you have well I did I I
asked that question in Berkeley and beat
and defeated my entire point but but
it's somewhere around 1% the insurance
guys tell me that now how many of you
have fire insurance
you fools it's much less much less than
10% so it's around 1% so when somebody
tells me that 10% is too small a number
what I keep coming back and saying what
are you talking about it depends upon
the problem it depends upon your degree
of risk aversion it depends upon what's
important I mean what do you think the
probability was of a whole bunch of
threats to our security for which we
have a RAND Corporation analyzed
using them all the time I happen to not
mind my tax money going into that I
think we should do that and almost every
corporation is worried about downside
risk oh my god if we do that what could
we don't get wiped out and then they
hedge so that's called risk management
and and Henry was way ahead of the curve
on realizing that this problem was going
to have inherent uncertainty for a long
time and that it was basically going to
be a risk management problem not a
problem of optimization so that's of
course the lesson and I can't help but
shamelessly come to the house the house
of Vanna White I mean to the to the
place where first guy who showed this to
me was Mort Webster but I don't know
which of you got the idea first but
congratulations to the group Ron it's a
great thing and I show the regular
audience as a PDF and I said that's a
PDF you can understand yeah they
understand and they get it and out here
oh my god
out here well we've warmed up so point
seven five and we've have intensified
hurricanes right Kerry still gonna stay
with that he's nodding yeah and so even
the small one is not trivial but it's a
heck of a lot less serious in terms of
the number of systems and the degree to
which the systems are damaged than out
here and out there you're looking at Ice
Age interglacial cycle temperatures you
know ten two hundred times faster so
this is a nice way to get people to
think I think this was for your baseline
case that was approximately a tripling
of co2 something like that in 2100
alright so when you talk about
uncertainty you gotta talk about
probability so let's get on with that so
how do we do our analysis in the future
what are the future implications of
population affluence and technology
growth projections that's the old
Holdren Ehrlich I Pat Wright impact
population times affluence times
technology I was amazed once when a
petroleum engineer told me that oh
that's just a model I said no no it's an
identity it's true by definition it just
doesn't tell you anything until you know
that there's interactions among all
those terms now you need a model for
that but but just the multiplier is is
is true by definition so how do you
scientifically quote-unquote analyze the
future because the questions that were
asked in our plenary agreed outline are
what's going to happen not just what
happened that how confident are you but
what do you think will happen and how
confident are you and what does it mean
so we have to be doing projections I
kind of like that one this is one of
those tabloid things in about every five
years I find it again they bring it back
out figuring the ones if they could read
who read it the first time will forget
but actually a side of the joke there's
something very real so in order to do
the future you need one of these and
Nostradamus is crystal ball is clear
unfortunately and that's why we're all
here employed right the good news it
keeps us working the bad news is I wish
we knew the answers better is our
crystal balls look a little more like
that one I found that one in a pawn shop
and I immediately photographed it
because that's how I feel about it
it's not all cloudy you can see through
some of it and some parts so here's
cloud feedback in here and in there we
you know we've probably got rid of
forcing we got that one down better but
not aerosols so there are components of
things that we know pretty well we know
that reefs are in pretty big trouble
above two degrees warming maybe even
above one on some of them but then we
really we know that there's a large
threat to species but we don't know how
long that commitment will they take
whether if we had a transient they could
be recovered so there are large
components of the problem still pretty
opaque other parts that are pretty
well-established so then people say well
what about the future you guys are going
to be assigning likelihoods but
likelihoods sound like frequencies and
frequencies you know our observations so
of course I love doing this with
students right what's the probability
this is ahead just ahead on the Swiss
coin or a tail I just had to give a talk
there and I quickly pulled out the coin
I happen to have in my pocket you know
the now that you have you have these
cameras you can sit there and get it in
your PowerPoint in five minutes and of
course somebody said a half and I said
how do you know and they said two sides
and the usual manner I do with kids is
so you're a theorist
supposing you weren't capable of
understanding the theory of coin this
could you figure it out and they say
sure you flip it you know kids I do this
with high school kids they get it too so
you have head and tail and you check the
box and you get through and that's the
best tradition of science go out and get
the data so now of course I'm gonna now
trick them a little what's the frequency
data on the future
well how about none so how can we make
probabilistic statements that's where
the cloudy partly cloudy crystal ball
comes along the way we make statements
in the future is we construct a model
which we hope characterizes enough
processes that when you push it under
alternative scenarios of growth or
activity you can start differentiating a
high emission scenario from a low you
can look at what it means and you're
going to be honest and open that it's
not going to be a perfect replica of
reality but the degree of confidence you
have is going to depend upon how well it
does on current conditions so how do you
assess I'll go through this fast
everybody here knows this but this is
the framework that we have to deal with
when you're trying to talk to
decision-makers and there are it's not
always an oxymoron there are honest
decision-makers out there but they need
to be led through this because there's
so much nonsense of oh it's too
uncertain you can't do probabilities in
the future all that can't sure you can
but they're subjective but they're
expert at the same time and you have to
do mix systems and if they're not based
upon if the systems aren't constructed
based upon good data and theory then
your confidence in them is very low but
just because it is you're not certain
that in the future under different
conditions that the way you derived your
equations will still be true well we
believe that they'll sure be true for
Newton's laws but we're not sure that
the parameterization of clouds inside
them that we derive from current
conditions will absolutely be true in
the future so we have to spread the
tales of our PDF as we get further out
to be able to represent it so how do you
do it and I try to tell them we have no
replicate Earth's you can't run a
hundred Earth's pollute half of them and
see what happens it's one place no but
we do have Mars and Venus the test
process
so people say AHA Marsden atmosphere
huit greenhouse effect cold Venus thick
atmosphere strong greenhouse effect hot
earth medium right in the middle which
which lynn margulis once called
planetary Goldilocks theory right too
hot too cold just right the trouble is
it doesn't help you much we already knew
from experiments and labs you know what
he trapping was it's nice to have it
work at a large scale and a planet Peter
used to do stuff like that you know
years ago but the truth is what makes
the Earth's climate sensitivity
uncertain a factor of three or four is
hydrologic cycle it's cloud feedback an
ice and other internal dynamics
unfortunately unique to the earth so
we've got a little bit of help out there
but not a lot we don't have any clinical
trials I can't resist but that's another
talk for another day about doctors
clinical trials and cancer treatments I
have a book the patient from hell it's
about the application of Bayesian
methods as opposed to clinical trials to
rare diseases which I had and I still
have but it's five and a half years
later and I'm still here when I should
have been dead with a 95 percent chance
because if you can't cure it what I said
very simple precautionary principle
Henry Kendall if you can't cure it
manage it so you can't get rid of it
don't wait for it to come back let's use
low-dose prophylactic immunotherapy and
keep the numbers of the cells down I
don't care if I have cancer I care if I
have a trillion cells ladder dead
million cells nothing
just potential keep it down so finally
we've got that and it works so far okay
you never know you could get the cysts
of the can mutate and then drug won't
work then you have to really deal with
it but I don't have any higher
probability of that than any of you so I
just what I keep saying back to your
wheel of fortune Ron is that in life you
can never control where the ball lands
or where the fortune of the wheel goes
and our job is to make the really lousy
slots narrower and the really good ones
fatter that's all we can do and you
can't that doesn't mean bad things won't
happen to good people it just happens
less and this is again
the whole philosophy that we try to
argue when we talk about this so you
don't have clinical trials and replica
turrets but we have analogies volcanic
dust fails we test those if you have an
economic model you want to run it on
price shocks you want to get any magic
spike of forcing and response that
although not a perfect analogy to the to
the global change problem at least gives
you some capacity to test the model
sensitivity because when you build a
model and derive it on the basis of
present data that doesn't validate it
you need to have external additional
things and that's standard so we have
stuff to do and of course we have our
virtual earths our models in the major
effort which a lot of which goes on here
and in other places is testing to ask us
confidence assess confidence because
confidence is essential it's become
essential in the IPCC Richard Boston I
wrote the guidance paper and uncertainty
for the third assessment report trying
to really get people to force them when
they use words like likely to have a
probability scale because there's been a
lot of Zhu Granger Morgan's work has
shown that people have an order of
magnitude difference in their mental
conception of the probability of a
likely we said we'll come on at least
let's be on the same page and IPCC's
been very good about that and
governments now have first they were
they were skeptical now they really like
this because they realize ordering their
risks requires how confident we are in
the science ok so here we go models and
data so this is the famous hockey stick
I'm not gonna argue about how wavy the
handle is it's probably wavier than that
and this is out from the noise and
that's also I'm not going to argue it
now but it almost undoubtedly the last
three four decades are but I want to
just show process so we have a fan of
uncertainty here what are those colored
lines those are scenarios with the awful
names the top one a one fi a one as a
globalized world of mobilized capital we
use all the available cheap energy coal
other fossil fuels without any tailpipe
dumping fee one of my colleagues called
it the world business as usual greed
it's a very rich world and population
stabilized
under 10 million the lowest one is b1
that's the world of egalitarian sharing
where where new technologies is shared
that's by the way the lowest on the sand
one notice it's curved over to the right
that means it has stabilized by the end
of the century it is a doubling of co2
and this one is still going up that
means we're going into tripling its
tripling over here and it's quintuplet
there so that's a pretty scary one and
that by the way is not the highest if we
use tar sands and oil shells and this
isn't the lowest if we have a
breakthrough in in in in deep earth
sequestration or nanotube solar or we
have a world depression let's not root
for that one that's not the way to solve
the climate problem and then there's a
technology one I like a lot that's we
spend 1% of GDP
so here's fan of uncertainty one human
behavior what about these vertical bars
that's fan of uncertainty - that's the
dynamics of the climate system they
represent so the bottom of that bar
means you've got a lot of emissions but
you have a model with relatively low
sensitivity to them up there you've got
a model with high and that constructed
in the this is the third assessment
report 2001 about 1.4 to 5.8 was the
range again it's your wheel and they did
not put a probability function through
there you had probability functions
because you had divisions so there are
many of my colleagues who would argue
that that was irresponsible because you
can't assign probabilities to future
social events I don't happen to agree
with that I think you can but they're
subjective and you have to have local
low or medium confidence in them but you
certainly can they didn't assign
probabilities it just gave you the range
okay let's unpack that a bit so here's
model one this is what I'm calling the
well calibrated range so this is your
low climate sensitivity model PCM and n
cars
here's model to a medium one another
medium one model for maybe GFDL I mean
one of the models and it's how much you
warm up if you doubled co2 and so you
have a ray
and that was the one and a half to four
and a half and the Charney range and
I'll show you later what's just come out
from the new report and I'll show you
what they proposed versus what emerged
well everybody knows that processes are
left out because the partial
differential equations can't be solved
by known calculus so you have to
discretize you've got grain sizes that
are much larger than individual clouds
we've got parameterization the usual
story economists call it reduced form
where you're we're in an economic model
you have an agent - perfectly foresees
the future and who then maximizes
utility which is typically the log of
consumption and this agent is called
representative though there's lots of
studies that it isn't representative
it's representative of some firms and
you can argue that indefinitely and we
don't need to argue that here I have no
problem with anybody who makes
assumptions I only have problem when you
call them high confidence and the in
fact models all models are of course is
the logical consequences of explicit
assumptions which in my opinion beats
out hand-waving
anytime but when you start doing that
you've got to make alternative
assumptions at different groups believe
and show the alternative consequences so
anyhow we know processes are missing so
the judge range is larger and when
Granger Morgan and David Keith did a
decision analytic survey they got
climate sensitivity range that was
larger than the models which is what
you'd expect in cognitive psychologists
like Conor menisci say wait a minute
even you scientists are suffering from
inherent bias and from anchoring which
means you see what's out there and from
availability what did you read last week
and that we to have prejudice and that
even though the we with that prejudice
would come out on our judge ranges but
probably the uncertain is even larger
than we think so the full range which we
won't know for a long time is even
bigger
that's the context though in which we
operate most of what's in IPCC is in
here
recognize this yeah you must that's
that's the work this is in the forest a
tall paper here of PDFs of climate
sensitivity one with a uniform prior one
with an expert prior that was Morgan and
Keith I won't go over it other than to
say it's very typical it's got a long
right-hand tail there's another one from
and Renova and Schlessinger which also
has a long right-hand tail with a bump
physically where did that come from
where do they get three four five six
degrees warming from doubling of co2
because we know with pretty high
precision how much heat trapping we've
had from the co2 methane and other gases
emitted that's pretty well controlled
but we also have aerosols Hayes's which
reflects sunlight and cool and some of
them even warm the soot ones and when
they get mixed up in clouds that can
change the amount of drops you change
the amount of drops you change the
reflectivity of the cloud depending on
the color of the particle and therefore
this is called an indirect aerosol
effect and it and the direct co2 and and
greenhouse gases what two to three watts
per square meter pretty well constrained
whereas the aerosol effects run from
minus half a watt to minus 1.5 well how
would that make the long tail because if
the indirect effects were very large
that means that the world is only
experiencing one one and a half watts in
the last hundred years so when you look
at the warming and you scale it you'd
actually have much higher climate
sensitivity because you reflected it
away so I've heard people say oh isn't
that good so why don't we just run those
Hayes's out there to offset the growth
of global warming and I said wait a
minute
I don't know that acid rain and air
pollution that sends kids to the
hospital with asthma is a good way to do
that and in fact the economists have
shown us that in every society as it got
richer we cleaned up the air not because
of climate but because of health and
that's also happening in China and India
right now and I think it'll continue so
we don't we can't rule out that nasty
tail because we don't know currently the
indirect effects well enough to know how
to back it out
okay now update the AR for that's the
assessment report for we'd see the
previous one was thar third assessment
report
so why AR for you know why not FA our
well because that was the first and that
will be the fifth also so this was the
acronym there's Martin Manning and he
and I were in India at a meeting
recently for the synthesis and he's a
bird photographer and I'm well I'm a
twitcher I go count them so we went out
and had a good time anyhow let's go back
again I showed you this picture there's
the third assessment report one point
four to five point eight so now a
similar study six years later was put by
working group one to the plenary the
plenary is when the hundred governments
get together four hundred
representatives and word-for-word
approve the summary for policy makers by
deciding what to take from the chapters
it can't change the chapters but they
decide what they think is of
significance and what you'd expect
fossil fuel dependent states try to
spend the report down in seriousness
small island states coastal dwellers or
others who have concerns where they
think that they're a victim of the
impacts try to spin it up and then the
scientists job is not to let that happen
and in the end you have to negotiate it
you don't have a report and the process
amazingly works but it works very very
frustratingly so here is the old one now
what does the new one look like
so this I've blocked out something this
is what was proposed by working group
one fourth assessment report in its
plenary to the hundred governments I
apologize for the lousy graphics because
we as we just heard they're not
available yet and the in the good form I
just got that and there's that from a
preliminary one so here's the same thing
there's except they don't run the hockey
stick back they just run the present
observations this one is an unimaginable
miracle which is that concentrations
stay fixed now for the century not
emissions because of emissions are fixed
you're still going to double just in a
hundred and fifty years so
concentrations stay fixed still warms up
another six seven tenths of a degree
sort of doubles the warming we've
already had then here are three
scenarios be
the egalitarian sharing a balanced one
and A two which is a really nasty world
its regionalized
not much globalization it's got a lot of
population remember the top one from the
previous one a one fi the fossil
intensive right now that looks like
current business as usual it was not in
there
well what would have happened if
governments didn't force this on the on
working group on governments insisted
that the plenary put in a one fi so they
added that and then they put in these
bars but these bars are different these
are calculated and models what these
bars represent and I applaud working
group one from Duke for doing that even
though some of the scientists they were
uneasy about it is they recognized from
the literature that there's a medium
confidence that the ecosystems of the
world which are currently believed not
the cutting down of treat art given that
you've got a certain stature of forests
that they will absorb some of the co2
emitted into the atmosphere thereby
being a negative feedback on
concentrations right a stabilizer but as
you get hotter you decompose organic
matter in the soils at a much faster
rate you start threatening switching
from sink to source and you start
damaging forests and so the literature
is suggesting somewhere between a couple
of degrees and four you're going to
switch the ecosystems I don't know Jim
what do you think from source to from
from sink to source so they built into
the top of these bars for the warmer
scenarios an added half to one degree
that's meant to represent that positive
feedback I think that's completely
legitimate appropriate risk management
and they explained that I they were
initially very reluctant I don't quite
understand why maybe you know Peter like
they just get nervous about being
subjective on the other hand how can you
not tell that to government's because
part of the risk decisions they have to
make includes that so good for them for
doing it and good for the governments
for saying you got to do it because
that's the authority the government
have so this is the table you don't
don't worry I won't make you see it 1.1
to 6.4 is the new range but I want you
to see this below is 1.1 if they had not
put in a1 f5 the top would have been 5.4
I could see the headlines IPCC reduces
seriousness of global warming the third
assessment report was one point four to
five point eight the fourth was one
point one to five point four that's the
reason the government's insisted on a
one fi because they wanted to make it
comparable to the third assessment
report so you're comparing apples with
apples it's still not completely
comparable because the top number
includes that extra bump that was not
included in the tar and wasn't included
in the models from from the
decomposition or the organic matter and
or that the the shrinking of forests and
I think it's good that they did that
it's good that they were clear but in
the world out there people don't read
the fine print don't understand it and
therefore when you're doing a series of
reports that have non comparability it's
very easy for people to misinterpret
that as the science having gone up or
down when in fact it's just a different
framing and that's all part of what we
have to do this is also from the AR four
and this is what I call the sheared blue
tornado and I like this figure a lot I'm
afraid we'll have to spend a minute or
two on it what it says is so here's
today three hundred and whatever it is
parts per million global mean
temperature increase around 0.75 these
are projections forward in time so
here's co2 stabilization levels so what
is that let me see my next one should
have that no how does how come it's
missing and well it's missing a slide or
it's not finding it I'll explain it then
all right
what doubling of pre-industrial is from
280 to 555 60 so that's what this line
is so this is a doubling so that co2 is
doubling of pre-industrial I had put in
some slides that actually show you
and label it sorry about that and they
said it was likely based upon their
reading literature this is the first
significant change in the Chinese one
and a half to four and a half they now
called likely two to four and a half
okay likely is 66% that means you've got
if it's symmetrical and nobody knows the
that 17% on either side right 17 and 17
is 34 plus 66 last time I checked is the
whole thing so that's what they did so
four and a half to two but then they
assessing the literature particularly
looking at paleo climate and some other
multiple runs that from the had center
where they did a Monte Carlo with
different values of parameters they said
it was very unlikely that's the phrase
up here that the climate sensitivity is
less than one and a half so there we are
10% because IPCC defined very unlikely
is less than 10% that's defined that was
in the guidance paper that we forced on
them that everybody's bought and the 7%
was a residual so here we are 17% chance
that it's beyond that
oh okay so here's the language unlikely
means less than 33 more than 10 very
unlikely less than 10 so now here's the
tornado again okay I did get it in I
just put it in the wrong place apologize
so it's missing something so this is the
likely climate sensitivity range this
arrow should be going over to here
that's what happens when you do
something at three o'clock so there it
was so there's the likely climate
sensitivity range for two times co2 550
ppm
there it is I've got at least I got that
in right and there's the bar across
there but what about that remember the
language for less than 33 unlikely where
did that come from that approved
language is unlikely so I asked my
friends and colleagues where did you get
cannot be excluded that is not in the
guidance paper it's true by definition I
can't
exclude an asteroid collision with a
10-kilometer asteroid and I can't
exclude that you know that global
warming is here what does it mean and I
found out the reason they didn't call it
unlikely at least this is what I was
told somebody correct me if it's wrong
was because they didn't want people
playing in the shadow details of the
probability distribution that Henry
Kendall told them they're supposed to
because they don't like being away from
good constraining data I sympathize on
the other hand risk managers certainly
in the military and health and in
business that's exactly what they want
to know
so I'll gonna switch to a little little
sports humor here I can't help but I was
in Colorado as you said for 20 years I
still Bronco fan so this was Denver's
defensive end when they were really good
defensively and they were the best
defense in the league in the middle of
the season and they were about to play
Indianapolis who was the best outfit so
everybody was you know hyping up this
game so they asked the defensive end
what was going to happen predict the
point total on Sunday because Denver had
apparently the second lowest point total
in the history of the NFL for the first
six games okay and he said I'm not
predicted nothing all I'm gonna predict
is a good game and I'm hoping the
Broncos come out on top and then he said
if I make predictions and it goes the
opposite way that I look like a horse's
fanny
well Henry I ain't trying to look like a
horse's Fanny right now in other words
this very good defensive end should be
in the in the risk management business
because he has type one error aversion
now explain that okay so economists long
ago I may have learned this from you
John but 2,900 years ago I hate to tell
you two ways it's false negative false
positive that's what it really is so
type one is we're not sure but we're
have concern we alert society they
invest money for something it doesn't
happen the ultimate example of that is
you're an earthquake forecaster in LA
you see some chance that in the next two
weeks some of your indicators tell you
there could be a major
creig if you announce it 200 people are
gonna get killed in car crashes there's
going to be thousands staying behind who
are loot the National Guard is gonna
arrest and shoot some didn't have a
horrible event so I don't want to risk
that I'm like the defensive end or
working group one I'm type 1 error
averse I don't want to give you a wrong
forecast I don't say anything
probably the forecasts will be false I
mean will be will I think this is
backwards let's get it right so the
decision in a type-1 is the policy
response files okay if the forecast is
false that's right that's right you make
a type 1 error
you gave a forecast didn't happen all
those people died you know leaving the
town and we had the horrible riot ok
with it with the remainders so you've
squandered resources and wasted stuff
and if the forecast is true well it's a
good thing supposing you didn't want to
take the risk and you didn't want to get
blamed for all that side effect and it
happened then you have unmitigated
damages and 10,000 people dying and
there's no right or wrong answer type 1
type 2 is not about science it's about
personal values on risk aversion you
know are you precautionary like Henery
or you precautionary on the forecast and
so scientists are innately tend to be
type 1 error verse because we don't like
to you know say stuffily we're really
not very confident in it and society and
and many people who face risks like to
be type 2 error verse so what's our role
assess risk consequence times
probability of occurrence and you do it
as a function of alternative policy
choices and then it's also our job
confidence in the assessment of risks
the distribution of risks and benefits
and then a traceable accounts of
aggregations we've talked about all
those already what about the role of
decision-makers their job is to
negotiate the acceptability of risks and
policies that alter risks make choices
and then also suggest the assessment
process we don't always choose to study
what they think is important we often
tend to look at what's interesting or
what we can get data on rather than what
they need so that's where the the merger
of scientist
and the decision-making process works
well and whether we're going to sit
there and worry a lot about giving a bad
forecast or whether we're gonna worry a
lot about we didn't hedge by ignoring
the forecast because of uncertainty that
in a way is the decision-makers choice
we should not be withholding information
because of that though we should just be
putting the confidence that we have in
it out there oh good I'll get there
thank you you want to spin that wheel
and see where I what I get now so here's
the competing paradigms between the
science and policy communities so it's
it's it's common in policy right the
incorrect forecasts taken Beecher is
type one decision two ignores type two
we've already said that there's just a
quick summary and what this argues and
don't don't bother to read it because I
just said it is that risk managers often
prefer to hedge against potentially
damaging event and those of us giving
the forecast don't like to give bad
advice so that's something which if both
sides understand it that we can do a
better job than doing it
of course type two error version that's
Henry right stop them at the outset and
don't wait until the results are
presented to us in the troubles of
developed so he's clearly and I am
personally as well my value systems are
in type two error aversion up to a point
you know I don't know what I do in the
LA case I really want to have first
decimal point odds before I denounce it
but those are not easy choices and but
it's the nature of the business that
we're in when we're starting to bring
science together in the policy world
okay now what about dangerous
anthropogenic interference I do this
I'll just show you a few minutes of the
personal work that I do that we also
have assessed no sorry about that came
out lousy Mike Mastin drea my colleague
and I published a paper on probabilistic
assessment we always put the quotes
around dangerous not just because we're
quoting the UN Framework Convention but
because I don't know what it means so
we're gonna it's it's it's a how do you
define it paper this is in PNAS and this
is our mantra every single time I give
talk this is it owing to the many model
dependent assumptions inherent in the
use of such highly simplified models we
emphasize that our quantitative results
using this simple model and not intended
to be taken literally we do suggest the
probabilistic framework and methods be
taken seriously they produce relative
trends and general right conclusions
that represent risk management approach
so that's the frame now if you're going
to give anybody something quantitative
you have to make assumptions and you're
gonna run a model which is going to give
you numerical answers and so what our
philosophy is let's run the model many
times under different beliefs and see
how that changes the outcome so now
we're going to talk about climate policy
as risk management we've already seen
those other slides and that means
assessing risk is a function of policy
choices so what are the policy choices
well we did run the fan of uncertainties
at IPCC had but not in the particular
study I'm going to show you we went and
used O'Neal and Oppenheimer's scenarios
and the reason I use them as I think my
own personal belief is an overshoot is
more likely than anything else this is I
wish they had these in color I just got
it I can't well I'll just walk you
through it so this is radiative forcing
watts per square meter associated with
various emissions scenarios 2020 120 250
500 parts per million co2 equivalent a
little bit below doubling over
pre-industrial so the scenario one is FC
slow change gradually sidles up to the
equilibrium stabilization here's
scenario two that's that one that is a
more rapid change but it still
stabilizes so in this case we start out
using the coal and oil but we invest a
lot in alternatives that we kind of
invent our way out of the problem after
a big orgy this is an even bigger orgy
this is more than doubling co2
equivalent so there's the slowly
changing world the rapidly changing
world and then there are these two this
one is an overshoot of the 500 that
comes down to 500 so what we do in this
period
is bigger orgy invent your way out of it
and then in here even bigger the same
thing so these are overshoot scenarios
which my own personal view is more
probable than the slow changes I don't
know what you think Mort jog you're not
gonna now you're not gonna you're gonna
make me hang out here and do it Mike if
you know if you could convince me you
had diety status and you put me on some
very painful electric device and asked
me to sketch what I think the scenario
is gonna look like I'm gonna probably
sketch one in between that one in that
one I think we're gonna overshoot and
come down I do think we're gonna get
smart and stop this but not right away
but okay it doesn't matter what I think
our job is not what I think it's what
the models tell you under a range of
assumptions in the literature so this is
an interesting one because this is a
tremendous challenge to science so Dai
dangerous anthropogenic interference
what's the threshold below which were
okay and above which we're not I don't
believe in such a thing it's in the
Framework Convention because already
we've passed the threshold where some
species will probably driven to
extinction I'm going to guess the polar
bear a crow system is already
functionally extinct and so forth but
it's not a lot of systems and the degree
of magnitude is not so much above four
degrees I think we're gonna have
worldwide systems in every sector in
every location very seriously affected
into a deep degree so therefore where
you said it is back to that value
judgment about things so if you take
what the EU did they picked two degrees
above pre-industrial two degrees above
pre-industrial means point one point
four above 2000 at the last IPCC report
because it already warmed up six tenths
and one point two five above now that's
pretty probable so the likelihood of
exceeding it is high so you have the
mean exceedance amplitude and then you
have this what we call dy it's like it's
like air conditioning you want to figure
out what's your
air conditioning load what do you have
to have in the power plants you you add
up to greed ace so you look at the
degree years what's the total area under
the curve and time really matters
because if it happened sooner it's
harder to adapt if happens later it's
easier so that's basically the the
thresholds that we're we're looking at
okay sorry for the complexity but here
we have a CDF an exceedance CDF out I'll
stop after the next one we've gone far
enough this is the probability of
exceeding so here's the EU threshold
right
it's 1.4 because they said two degrees
above pre-industrial I have to take the
6/10 away because this is above 2000 so
there's their threshold so now you're
gonna ask what's the probability of
exceeding that for the slow change
scenario in 2200 or for the overshoot in
2200 that's the yellow those are these
two okay where did that come from that
came from taking the three functions I
showed you the probability functions for
climate sensitivity and stupidly
averaging them with equal weights now
there's a lot of reasons not to do that
but we're not we're only here to
demonstrate framework so we did it
rather than pick one of them it it
doesn't matter if the numbers change the
object is to see what it means so
there's about a 45 percent chance that
that threshold of the EU will be
exceeded above the 2000 level for even
the slow changing one as the 55 percent
chance in the overshoot in 2200 but
remember it exceeded and then came down
supposing what mattered was the top
temperature may I don't know maybe
that's gonna trigger some kind of ice
melt you can't stop or some species
extinction this is what I said what a
challenge the scientific community we
not only do we have to figure out how to
do climate transients driven by
transient emission scenarios we got to
figure out how to do impacts transients
because that's probably the scenario
we're gonna get and if you take a look
at the peak temperature in the 500
overshoot
seventy-four 7% chance of exceeding it
so we can end with this one it's worse
than I just said because now here we are
seven years later there's been an
increase in temperature it's now they
say 0.75 not 0.6 so the new EU dangerous
number is 1.25 and if I move this thing
back now we're looking at a 55% chance
on the slow for 2007 now all these
numbers again don't take them literally
but the way that I think we need to
frame the problem is as a risk
management problem and the key to that
is to try to get people to be a bit more
literate about what that means and I'll
end gratuitous leer on because I stole
this from him when he and I were at Ways
and Means Committee giving testimony and
you made the mistake of having it on a
jump drive that I quickly took all right
so here's there's the first one right
there's your famous one from your
unmitigated co2 tripling have you all
seen this before all right I'll give you
a little a little shameless pandering I
think this is very cool all right so now
let's invest whatever it takes trillions
of dollars who knows is all kinds of
debates about that and now you get a new
wheel so there's the wheel with only co2
doubling no I don't know how you did
this this is really really cool so when
I show this to my students they like it
a lot I said so okay kids which world
you want to be on huh that one that one
that one I said but it might cost
trillions of dollars and then they asked
a very good question well what does that
mean I don't know what trillions of
dollars means and I said well it means a
large fraction of current GDP in a
trivial fraction of future GDP in fact
I've done work on this to my website
Christians are and I am what we
basically showed was that if you really
project the growth rate in the economy
at 2% per year and you lost 2% of the
economy a hundred years from now that's
like seven trillion dollars just in one
year it sounds unimaginably high 50% of
the current US economy but a 2% per year
that's made up in two years so what you
end up with is being 500 percent for
capita richer in 2102 with the 350
dollar it's on carbon tax it keeps you
to 450 ppm versus being 500% richer in
2100 with whatever you get on the
roulette wheel and for me that's cheap
insurance even though it's an absolute a
lot of money so the question then is
how's the political world going to react
and we can get people literate enough to
understand these ideas so that they
realize that these really don't require
that sophisticated and understanding
we're talking about risk management with
a life support system and that's how at
least I try to frame it when I talk to
those groups and it's very tough to
frame it this way when you have 20
seconds soundbite on the evening news
it's a little easier in Congress and
graphics like that Ron and your group
thank you this helps a lot thank you all
so we're ready for questions so just put
your hand up and I think the comments
pretty good here and I did it under the
time you told me to stop yes no that's
well within that era bar that I did all
right yes
[Applause]
I happened to hear a bill Nordhaus was
at Harvard a week or so ago and he's
done some recent work where he seems to
be he's an economist at Yale and yeah
and I wonder if you could you could just
briefly summarize what you think he's
saying currently and your understanding
your ear and your assessment of his
current analysis let me start in the
back with with Bill I don't know what
his current one is because I'll be at
the energy modeling forum this summer
and he'll show it do you know John or
Mort or somebody what Bill's done lately
I know he's been trying to incorporate
nonlinear effects you know in and making
his damage functions have much longer
tails but I don't know
and so obviously in this business as I
said don't ever take model dependent
results very literally till you unpack
til you unpacked the assumptions and in
fact I know bills dice model very well
because the see it's right at dynamic
integrated climate economy model to see
is Schneider and Thompson 81 and the
reason I recommended to Bill to use that
simple two box globally averaged model
because it was just as bad as the
globally averaged economic model that he
was using and Bill did not build it to
forecast the world he built it to do
sensitivity analysis for which I thought
that was responsible now how some people
have used it is another story so will
argue that out my largest debate with
Bill and sometimes John and the whole
community is I don't use market interest
rates when I'm discounting
sustainability not on cost-benefit
analysis because I don't think my my
child as a more valuable life than my
grandchild I use it when we're doing
cost-effectiveness that is if you've
picked a target for reduction based upon
a political negotiation about weighing
across all the multiple metrics remember
I said this thing's traded in markets
and ecosystems and species and inequity
which you're just talking about New
Orleans how you aggregate those into any
single thing depends upon the weight you
put on the various metrics that's that
science that's values so my own view is
you should react gate multiple times
with different values and different
weight functions and then have a
political negotiation but once you've
picked in the political world how much
you want to stay under five fifty four
fifty whatever it is then you of course
want to have the economists with
discount rates with every good tool they
have to try to get us there most
cost-effectively that's my own personal
view which is that picking picking
targets is not amenable to cost-benefit
analysis but finding out how to do it
once you pick the targets is in fact
requires for efficient resource use good
economic methods so we could argue that
or others but that's that's my my own
prejudice as far as sinking the one end
of the boat is concerned there is no
doubt and and and and Henry said that
remember he said the poor will be hurt
more but New Orleans was gonna happen
with or without climate change I have
been to no less than ten meetings in my
life before New Orleans with people
showing slides I could show you I don't
have it on this chart of it's mostly
below sea level saying any category 3
plus hurricane is going to make that
city history and what did they do they
chose to cut taxes to top brackets
rather than invest 10 billion dollars on
fixing the levees that was a political
decision not a geophysics decision and
what warming does right Kerry is it
increases the likelihood of some
increased intensity storms sometime over
a city's lifetime and therefore we don't
know whether the half degree warmer and
the Gulf was worth what 3 inches or two
feet of the storm surge we'll never know
in any one storm so we can't say we did
it on the other hand what you do is you
shrink the time between these
catastrophic events by warming it up so
right now we're it was six seven tenths
of a degree warming for that one you
want to talk about sinking both ends of
the boat when you're talking about three
to six degrees warming there's not going
to be very many there's no literature on
very many benefits after three degrees
and also in a world of that kind of
stress and this is what what a number of
military advisors and strategic planners
are saying is that kind of a world is
not a world that lowers the probability
of conflict and therefore and it's not
that climate change is going to create
conflict you have to go to an area where
human behavior and historical animosity
and all kinds of factors make it
vulnerable now you add on top of it an
outside force that increases stress we
don't need that on top of what we've
already got so that's what I would would
argue so I think Henry was
using it metaphorically meaning the
larger changes down the stream and that
we wouldn't be exempt from world
problems associated with they're getting
hit harder than us and I think that's
probably fair I don't think he was
trying to imply that the scale of our
economy that would be damaged would be
the same as the scale of the honduran it
was at Honduras in hurricane Mitch so we
lose 1% for a year and they lose 40%
what was the number was really bad so
that that didn't sink the ship yet
because it's still just isolated it's
when it goes beyond isolated that that
becomes a problem yeah
the uncertainty between policymakers of
developed countries and developing
countries that's a very good question I
don't know if everybody heard it out of
the pot what do I see the perceptions of
policymakers and developed in developing
countries first of all you could have
said how do I see the perceptions of
policymakers in the developed country
called the United States and I can tell
you the perceptions in California differ
radically from the perceptions in the
West Wing which now differ radically I
think Ron would agree after our
testimony and I'm now done three since
then from the Congress
so within us there is very very
different perceptions and a lot of that
comes out of a risk aversion and B
general ideology
do you believe protecting the commons is
your job but do you believe protecting
entrepreneurial rights is your job and
theirs that's deep ideology and that
often drives people's perceptions of the
seriousness of the problem is with whose
ox gets gored you know the victims of
the climate change of the victims of the
policy so that is not even constant
across developed countries look at
Europe versus the US or California
versus inside Washington and even as I
said inside Washington the other part of
Washington so now let's go back to the
developed developing divide and that's
bigger and it's bigger because we argue
a ton of carbon emitted in Beijing does
exactly the same thing to the ecology
and the sea level as a ton emitted in
Boston okay everybody agrees
therefore bird Hegel said on the day
that Henry testified to the White House
sooner when when the rest of us did that
therefore they don't want a policy if
there isn't a level playing field that's
not fair that our industry should be
taxed and we'll have leakage from China
and they went on all those arguments and
they forgot that we had a hundred year
Head Start that we had the Victorian
Industrial Revolution with sweatshops
coal burning internal combustion engines
and we got rich doing it and then as we
got richer we started to cut emissions
and started to worry about this problem
and they said well they know India China
when we catch up to you will take a
target so of course we said back yeah
but
you've got four times the population we
can't multiply that times the emissions
that we have because then we'll end up
co2 quintuplet or more and that's not
sustainable so now we have the blame
fingers going out I've seen this at cops
all the time
you colonialist power monopolistic
capital you know hoarding hoarding your
resources keeping your technology and
making us buy it and then not putting
your consumptive patterns up for
negotiation and then of course on the
other side you hear you in efficient
place without proper market incentives
to stimulate people and with corrupt
governments and too many people and of
course who's right both of them so how
do you solve the problem Trust ha you
talk to each other you say okay you
can't repeat the Victorian Industrial
Revolution with your population at the
rate that we did it but you don't have
to because we now invented high-tech we
have more of the patents and the skills
and you do I'll tell you what we'll fund
our companies give them tax breaks or
other money they can go over there with
a public-private partnership with you
you each co-owned the patents go invent
something get rich doing it you need to
have a leap frogging
over the Victorian Industrial Revolution
because right now what you're going to
get is blame and it's slowly changing
but what we need instead is cooperative
solutions and I think now we are closer
to that than I have seen in my career on
this and I started working on this stuff
in 1970 there was a small window in 1988
but that got closed by disinformation
campaign and we didn't have as strong a
scientific community buy-in as we do now
so I actually think we're gonna get
somewhere and there's plain ordinary
incentives to companies to really try to
be the ones that get that turn over
sooner because the ones who come up with
the cheaper batteries to store things
and the ones who come up with it with
the hot tower solar at you know near
coal prices even if it's a little above
if we have a shadow price that'll even
it up they're gonna be very rich
and and they should be so I'm hopeful
that we'll get around it that way but
the perception in the developing world
that if I'm going to let me let me frame
it nastily their view is that they're
willing to hold at least in rhetoric the
sustainability agenda the planet no
hostage their view of equity and we're
willing to hold it hostage to our view
of consumption neither of those are okay
and I'm hopeful when we have some
leadership that we'll be able to make
some good deals yes nuclear power when
this is one of the temples of you know
good thinking about that I'll answer it
by going way back to the bush one
administration when the president made
the statement in a campaign and
afterward that it would be no new taxes
and then the environmental groups were
saying no new nukes so I got asked once
by well many more than once by a
reporter and the reason the answer is
still relevant because it's what I still
believe as I said I hi try hard not to
be an ideologue and I tried to never say
no new nukes or no new taxes what I'll
say is no in a fish in efficient
inequitable taxes no dangerous
overpriced over subsidized energy
systems now do I think that's nuclear
then yeah does that have to be nuclear
in the future not necessarily but I'm
not going to get into the debate of the
details what I want to argue is its deal
with non meltdown able cycles with waste
disposal and I don't know whether it's
ceramics or something that's acceptable
I don't know that we want to subsidize
liability limitations it's a subsidy
without also subsidizing solar wind and
plug-in hybrids so my own view is if
we're going to invent our way out of the
problem and build an economy we would
probably need to subsidize everything
and I wouldn't leave nuclear out but one
area where I worry is in countries that
already that do not already have nuclear
weapons I worry about whether or not
anything that we sell them in terms of
radioactive products don't need to be
taken back that you have to have the
cost of the process include repossession
I don't mean you have to take it back
where it was but you have to be
responsible for that because and maybe
that has to be part of a deal and it
should be part of the cost I think the
Europeans now are requiring computer
companies to repossess the the computers
at the end so they don't end up in all
the landfills I mean so I think doing
some version of whole system accounting
and not just for nuclear but for
everything and then finding a way to
transition from now till then is the way
to go so I'm gonna repeat I'm not going
to be ideological about it I don't
personally think the costs are going to
encourage it very much in this country
until people figure out a way to bring
down the costs I doubt it's going to be
a serious option but that doesn't mean
it couldn't be in some places or even
here
if that happens others here must know
much more about it than I though I
encourage my environmental friends not
to be ideological okay this looks like
let's go in after reception to stop
there is now a reception that's up on
the fourth floor and MIT terms 34 - 401
hey a and B and that's on the fourth
floor of this building of course I'd
like to thank Steve Snyder for a very
stimulating lecture
you